one of president biden's first executive
actions
to stop the funds to build this
his predecessor's wall one of his
signature projects
of course it won't leave the u.s wide
open there was already a significant
amount of fencing and security on the
border
but activists say it's an important
gesture
we can't spend a single penny more on
the construction on a wall of hate of
shame
a racist wall anymore
mexican president andres manuel lopez
obrador is hoping for more
a path to citizenship for undocumented
migrants already in the united states
we've been proposing that our countrymen
who have been working for years
should be regularized contributing to
the development of that great nation
president biden does have a plan for an
eight-year path to citizenship
for more than 10 million people who
haven't got legal status
but there are many more still trying to
get there in the days before the
inauguration
thousands of hondurans were stopped in
guatemala before they could get near the
u.s border
others like mina castillo have reached
it but are still waiting in mexico for
their asylum hearing
in her case it's been a year and a half
we never thought we'd stay here in
mexico and we still have hopes of making
it to the united states
that's our dream and we will wait to see
what the new president will bring
president biden signaled that he'll be
more open-handed with asylum seekers
than president
trump which isn't saying much but his
big plan is to stop people fleeing their
countries in the first place
he's placed four billion dollars to help
tackle poverty
and violence in central america in
partnership with governments there
president biden has a plan to try and
temper corruption
in el salvador guatemala and honduras
too
and a lot's going to depend on whether
that works and it's a tough one in those
countries
and if the money can get to where it's
needed john holman
al jazeera mexico city